The routine of a desk jockey raises any thoughts of any pleasure or pain, leaving you only
with numbness and the slightest hint of hope that the only happiness to be found was higher
on the corporate ladder.
Chasing the sly, I transformed my desk into a dump for any tasks my peers couldn't be
bothered with, sucked up to the most vile excuses for people to ever wear a suit jacket,
and made a habit of replacing sleep with coffee.
I had given this company a piece of my soul, only to watch my boss give his daughter the
position I had dedicated all these years working towards.
I wanted to scream in his skull, I wanted to cry like a child, but I couldn't.
I had been completely hollow for years, but now I was at my lowest low, nothing more to
strive for, nothing more to work for, nothing more to live for.
I wandered the night in a daze of utter aimlessness, yet, after sinking into the dark, I soon found
myself bathed in light.
It was a woman whose opulent beauty contrasted my disheveled despair.
Why was it then that I had caught her attention?
Not of disgust or pity, but I was instead called to the front of the line in a queue
of some very important looking people.
Without a word, her eyes gave an invitation, and her smile brought me both comfort of her
presence and the courage to follow.
Before I knew it, I was tailing her like a child into a building I had no business being
in, yet one she had total command of.
Every respectable patron and worker there from the highest walks of life called her Queen,
and the nature of that level of respect also made her Queen to me.
She had said she had seen a familiar pain in me and spoke to me about an offer.
Not a new job, but a new lifestyle.
She had brought me to the VIP section of the building and had finally dawned on me, a fetish
club for the rich and powerful.
My work didn't even allow me time for dating, much less anything here.
My curiosity and fear were at odds, yet Queen was understanding and familiar with my flavor
of reluctance.
She believed we were kindred spirits, though I couldn't see it.
In display of influence, she contacted my work, securing me a paid leave in order to
stay in Wonderland with complete access to all of its faculties for a week free of charge.
At the end of my stay, I would have to give my answer to join her in this wild new life,
a return to mediocrity.
To say I enjoyed my stay was an understatement.
I was finally tasting what life's joys can offer.
After the hotel amenities, spa, bars, and 5 star buffet, my curiosity eventually turned
to the VIP lounge.
It was there where I found myself.
It was there where I found my answer.
The pleasure I had never even knew I desired, the pain I had no idea I needed, this is what
I deserved, I found it all here.
My body was subjected to sensations and punishments my deepest imagination could never conjure.
That was, until they had me dishing it out as well.
After getting just a taste of this life, I knew there was no way I could turn down Queen's
offer.
I was now bound to this place.
In my service to Wonderland, I had been transformed.
In bondage, I found my freedom.
Through pain, I knew pleasure.
Through submission, I had found my power.
Through domination, I had found my peace.
I became a premier worker whose services were demanded by the highest paying clients from
across the world.
Top execs, actors, even politicians would line up to get their fill of welts and rope
burn.
I had seen more money in the first month than I'd ever seen in a year of office work.
My newfound command over the sins of the flesh gained me respect of peers as well as Queen
herself.
We had grown close, a bit more than professionally.
Despite this, even I had no idea what was to come.
She never wanted us to worry, so she never told anyone of her condition, and it struck
her hearts like a bolt of lightning when the time came.
When she passed, the city itself seemed to stand still in respect.
She had left behind a golden legacy as a saint of whips and gags, a woman who allowed those
scorned by the pursuit of happiness to regain their sense of passion and power.
She saw that need in me as well as my talent for it, and so did the others.
So when she willed her entire empire to me, there were no objections.
Thanks to her, I have attained a sense of power and family that I could have never imagined.
I will make sure that Wonderland will always be a safe haven for the rejected and the hopeless.
So if you feel trapped, finding yourself in a life of all pain and no pleasure, why not
stop by a little while?
I can help you find both.